i hired an opposition research company
to go in and pull the voter registration
records of the white house press corps
these are public records anybody can do
it
and they discovered that by a ratio of
12 to one wow
white house are occupied by registered
democrats
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
former white house press secretary a fox
news contributor and author of the new
book i've got in my hand right now
suppression deception snobbery and bias
why the press gets so much wrong and
just doesn't care ari fleischer welcome
to the reuben report dave thank you for
having me ari i feel like you wrote this
book for me personally because this
basically gets to the heart of
everything that i do
every hour that i spend working on this
show
that the media is sort of a bigger
problem than almost anything else at the
moment uh but before we dive into the
book uh you have a really interesting uh
backstory and all that stuff how did you
get involved in politics what eventually
got you to the white house and then
we'll get into all this stuff well to
put in a nutshell it was totally an
accident
i i graduated from college i moved home
to play baseball and a friend of mine
had a brother who was managing a
congressional race they needed a press
secretary i knew nothing and i got the
job
which
tells you how little you need to know to
be a press secretary
and i fell in love with politics we lost
it was 1982
reagan stayed the course no republic
only one republican challenger won that
cycle but i got the bug i moved to
washington i was unemployed and i got a
job as a press secretary to a new york
congressman and that began a 16-year
career on capitol hill followed by the
bush campaign where i moved to texas in
1999 and then the white house do you
miss being in the thick of the political
madness
no
nothing is there nothing you miss about
it
i spent 21 wonderful years in washington
and i loved every one of the days i was
there and especially at the white house
and when i was communications director
of the ways and means committee after
republicans took control of the house
tremendous excitement and satisfaction
but i was never a washington for life
type so one day you just know your day
has come it's time to go and it hit me
after 21 long years um so i loved it i
loved standing at that podium dave at
the white house and i loved taking heat
i loved catching the curveballs the
fastballs and standing my ground on
behalf of a president and a person who i
really believe in
and that's what it's about if you
believe deeply washington is the town to
be in
and then go back home believe it or not
i watched many many many of those press
conferences that you were doing back
then they were sort of must-see tv and
and this will sort of segue us a little
bit to the book uh correct me if i'm
wrong the media's
treats um republican press secretaries
and republican administrations a little
bit different than democrat press
secretaries and administrations is that
fair to say yeah i just caught friendly
softballs from the white house press
corps you know they love conservatives
they love bush look
the truth is as much as things have
changed since i was press secretary 20
years ago and they have changed a lot
they've gotten a lot worse and nastier
the fact is right now peter ducey is
really fox news the only one those 49
seats asking hard questions to the biden
press secretary when i was press
secretary there were 49 seats asking me
hard questions
that's the problem the press takes sides
and they did back then but back then
david it was more just your liberal
conservative bias reporters still
thought their job at the end of the day
was be objective and tell the news fair
and not give their opinions on the air
today you watch cnn you watch almost
every show and they think their job is
to give opinions and that's what they do
and it's killing journalism
so when do you think that started
because i think anyone watching this
they get it that that's what i spend
most of my show doing at this point is
debunking a lot of the nonsense that cnn
new york times washington post that
they're putting out as fact when if you
just read the headline with a little
more a little more precision you will
see that it actually is opinion yeah
absolutely right look it started because
of two reasons one is technology the the
internet led to the decline of
advertising for print newspapers and it
changed how you can watch the news as we
had a proliferation of outlets so you
had conservatives watching conservative
media you had liberals watching liberal
media and newspapers had no more money
the only way they got money was from
their aberrat from their subscribers
and so they didn't want to alienate
their subscribers unlike an advertiser
who wanted you to appeal broadly to the
entire country so you have to be mindful
of staying somewhat
sensible and accurate
now you could let it rip and along came
more social media twitter and other
places where reporters felt really good
given their opinions they didn't value
objectivity anymore they wanted them
water followers they wanted the praise
of hollywood actors and actresses when
they let their opinion rep hence jim
acosta at cnn john harwood at cnn
daytime reporters who don't report they
opine and always from a far left point
of view anti-trump anti-republican and
then the other factor was trump
when trump emerged the press somehow
made the decision to save the republic
they decided the american people aired
in 2016 by not electing hillary and the
press was going to fix the mistake
so these snobs put themselves in the
position superior to the people and said
collusion is probably how come trump won
the steele dossier is credible and we're
going to put trump in the country
through years of misery to make the case
against him
and you know as i write in the book they
didn't put just their finger on the
scale they put their writing hand on the
scale and many of them put their entire
bodies on the scale and this is the
mainstream media today and that's why i
wrote the book david this is why i blew
the whistle on the press
i try to be fair
i will always call the balls and strikes
i supported president trump on policy
pretty much all the time
i regularly tweeted that i objected to
his behavior when he tweeted something i
thought went too far and was offensive i
called him on it but when i saw the
coverage of donald trump how biased
unfair get trump if it was anti-trump it
gotta bump coverage i said i'm gonna
write about this it's not good for the
country it's not good for democracy it's
not good for journalism when reporters
are in the tank
do you think that they would have done
the same thing to your guy george w bush
had social media been as big back then
because i remember very specifically one
day i used to live on the upper west
which is you know bastion of liberalism
colombia you and i remember during the
bush presidency and it was during the
iraq war when the media was going crazy
all the time and you were you were doing
the press uh press junkets and all that
stuff i remember walking out and there
was a guy with a table with books and i
remember every single book basically was
george w bush is the devil like every
single book and they were all being
bought of course and had social media
existed at the time my guess is they
would have done the exact same thing it
just would have happened earlier yeah i
know you're right about that and i think
one of the points i make in the book is
regardless of what president trump
decides to do whether he runs or doesn't
run they're going to do it to ron
desantis yeah they're going to do kirsty
known they're going to do it to ted cruz
or tom cotton
and here's where i have some sympathy
for president trump what he will tell
you is republicans don't fight hard
enough and that's why he does what he
does
and i think there's some merit to that
because he recognized the mainstream
media is in the tank they're out to get
them they're not fair they're not
objective and so it made him fight twice
as hard three times as hard
i wish sometimes he had just gotten it
with a little more subtlety or nuance
but that's not his nature he let it rip
uh everywhere he went he was a bull in a
china shop and he took a new china shop
with him everywhere he went
um
and so
it's a calibration issue but yeah
republicans and conservatives need to
fight because my conclusion writing this
book is that the media has turned to
activists the mainstream media and by
that i mean the new york times the
washington post abc nbc cbs cnn
they are activists for a cause and it's
a liberal cause my first chapter is
called original sin yeah and i went to
how much how many reporters are
democrats i hired an opposition research
company
to go in and pull the voter registration
records of the white house press corps
these are public records anybody can do
it
and they discovered that by a ratio of
12 to one wow
white house are occupied by registered
democrats now dave why isn't it
one-to-one
or why isn't it 12-1 republican to
democrat
news would be different if it was 12 to
1 democrat republican to democrat
but the white house press corps
journalism schools throughout america
newsrooms pretty much throughout america
but especially in washington and new
york
overwhelmingly cut from the same cloth
think alike act alike dress alike
tweedle like
democrats
and
there's another study i found in here
it's a pew research study
the only group of americans who say the
press understands them
are college educated democrats
if you're a democrat i totally agree you
say the press doesn't understand me
independence regardless of degree press
doesn't understand me and certainly all
republicans say that the press has dug
itself into a cul-de-sac they are
college-educated democrats who know how
to write and think only for fellow
college-educated democrats and if you
own a gun if your grandfather taught you
how to hunt if you think life begins at
conception if you pray every day
the press doesn't understand you and
that's a huge problem with journalism
do you think that they know that they're
biased i mean i think you're right when
you said the twitter thing before
twitter sort of unmasked it because then
every minute of every day they were
sharing their opinions and then over
time you know you could aggregate it and
go okay you guys obviously have a
certain point of view but i look at a
guy like you know i i hit cnn all the
time on my show jake tapper is always
thought of as the one non-insane guy
there but it's obvious he's a democrat
like do you think that they know what
they're doing or do they think they on
it do you think they honestly believe
they're pulling the wool over our eyes
they know it and i've talked to them
about it they know it a lot of them
privately acknowledge it
um but they won't do anything about it
and this is the problem because they're
too like-minded they're in denial and
they're in decline they're watching
their viewership go down they're
watching their ratings go down they're
watching the trust from the american
people go down but unlike any
corporation who would say when they have
a trend like that what's wrong with us
what do we need to do differently
reporters tend to say what's wrong with
america what do the americans think
differently so what do we do about that
what do we do about that i mean is it
that you know basically the new guy at
cnn just has to fire everybody i mean it
is is it as simple as that does it even
matter anymore i mean should any of us
care we know that the ratings are going
down should we just let them die let
them just go extinct no and here's where
i think i hope my book is a little bit
different i point these things out
because i lament them i want the press
to be fair i want them to be objective
it's so good for america if we can pick
up one source of news and say yep i
believe it i trust it now here's what i
think needs to be done about it without
the media telling us what we're supposed
to think
my solution to it is number one young
people conservatives need to get into
journalism it's healthy number two
journalism schools
newsrooms need to actively recruit
people who think differently journalism
needs a booster shot of independent
thought
and that's not going to come from the
same old people will come from more
conservative thinking people so if i'm a
journalism school if i'm the columbia
school of journalism when i interview
somebody i would say tell me what your
habits are what are your favorite
hobbies and if somebody says i like to
hunt i like to fish
i enjoy going to church
to me that is a sign of ideological
diversity that i want in my newsroom
these people are so hung up on sexual
orientation or gender or race as opposed
to the most powerful diversity of all
which is diversity of the mind the way
you think
so that's number one journalism schools
need to change conservatives need to go
into j school and then newsrooms and
this is where the cnn experiment is
going to be fascinating the new
leadership of cnn says they want to
return to objectivity i'm going to watch
them i want to see what they do we'll
see
so on the first point on the schools i
mean i i agree with you but do you think
there's honestly any chance in high hell
that that's anyone at columbia
university that's been completely
infected by this woke thing is going to
do it i mean do you think any any
professor of journalism is going to put
their butt on the line to do what you
just said right there yeah probably not
and again i lament it but that's that's
the solution because what's what's the
alternative the alternative as we
continue the trend we're on and here's
what that trend looks like
conservative media is booming yeah
conservative viewership continues to go
up liberal media it goes down but it's
not healthy for democracy again i want
to be able to pick up one source of news
and say i'm done for the day it took me
10 minutes i read it i accept it and
here's what we need to do now and then
you debate it in the political sphere
and you actually go to vote and whoever
wins wins the election and moves the
country
but we shouldn't have to as a people
read five sources of news to figure out
what is right and what is wrong and
weigh it and balance it
and i get that question all the time
where can i go and frankly i'll tell you
this too dave the best show on the news
in my opinion is the six o'clock evening
show on fox with bret bear
it is old-fashioned straight down the
middle good reporting it's not cut from
the same liberal cloth but it's not you
know ideological conservative show
either it's just straight reporting and
and i miss that i like watching that
show so speaking of fox since you're a
fox contributor and i go on fox a couple
times a week i find fox they never tell
me what to say i say whatever i want
often things that are against say the
general conservative line um i i'm
guessing that they let you say whatever
you want but feel free to correct that
if not but there's a constant move to
take them out i mean there is a constant
move to make sure that tucker who is the
number one cable news host in the
history of television cannot get
advertisers uh how does all that fit
into the the situation we're in right
now remember where that started
remember when barack obama tried to take
out rush limbaugh yeah he went after
rush by name it was a deliberate white
house effort to take down rush and then
they tried to do it to fox
look
and this is why i kind of do doubt that
the mainstream media is capable of
fixing itself
they lost their customers the only
reason fox found a home was because
people voted to leave the liberal
mainstream media because they were no
longer being served they recognized how
liberal the media became
and it's kind of like china with taiwan
the mainstream media does not like the
fact that there's a breakaway that
there's one group that thinks
independently that thinks differently
that recognizes that the ways of the
liberal mainstream media are not the
ways of most americans and so they need
to take down fox just like china wants
to reabsorb taiwan
and again look at the ratings the
american people have rejected what the
mainstream media is doing that's why fox
is so popular they struck a niche they
found a home with an independent
different thought and it can't be
stopped
but fox is really alone you have fox you
do talk radio you do podcasts you do
have now have a new type of electronic
front the federalist the daily examiner
things of that nature the daily wire
but again it's the balkanization of
american information
and
i read left right and center but man i
have to work hard to figure things out
again i think it'd be easier for the
american people if we had faith in one
as opposed to have this balkanization
how much of this do you think is
connected to sort of the progressive
takeover of the democrat party that say
when you were press secretary and as you
said you were there was a little more of
a blend of reporters in there okay
the answer is different but we can
basically agree on the facts that now
you know basically the modern left the
democrat party they don't believe
america is fundamentally decent they
don't seem to believe in our founding
documents or separation of powers or all
of these things so that of course is
then going to leak into the people who
are translating the news to the average
guy and it's even worse than that dave
because you have a young generation of
reporters who think their job is to be
subjective not objective they think
there's something wrong with objectivity
there was a study that came out just
last week it was a pew study of
journalists and it reported that the
majority of journalists don't believe in
telling two sides of the news anymore
that they view one side as
misinformation it shouldn't be told well
whose opinion is it if it's information
or misinformation
and it said that
news outlets whose audiences lean left
by two to one don't think they should be
telling both sides of a story and then
it surveyed journalists who worked at
news outlets whose audience leans right
and by then 60 40 it was said that you
should cover two sides of the story so
who's being fair who is being objective
and who is being lopsided
and it's this the the takeover of
journalism by these young social
warriors which is what they are
is killing journalism and it happened at
the new york times one of my favorite
parts of the book is what happened when
senator tom cotton wrote
that online for the new york times that
the new york times headlines send in the
troops and it was in the summer of 2020
after the george floyd murder and riots
were everywhere 150 federal buildings
were damaged and tom cottons had sent in
the troops
a meltdown in the new york times
newsroom young reporters one after
another after another tweeted that this
was violence to them
violence was in the streets the violence
was with the poor people who ran mom and
pop shops that were being torn down and
looted and destroyed
but it was these people sitting in a
cubicle in manhattan who said this is
violence
and they forced the new york times to
tuck its tail to retract the op-ed to
say it never should have been run in the
first place to fire their editorial page
editor reassign the deputy editorial
page editor it was a purge
it was like a college campus broke out
inside the new york times where the
young people demanded the administration
silence a voice with which they disagree
it was one of the worst most
embarrassing episodes to be a media
organization dedicated to free speech
but free speech didn't stand a chance
against the young social warriors of
journalism yeah and that's also why
for me personally to me these things
have been infected i i don't think cnn
can come back you know when i give talks
at college campuses if i say cnn i used
to say cnn and then i would make a joke
now if i just say cnn they laugh cnn is
already to the punch line just saying
those three letters is already the punch
line so something like the new york
times i mean barry weiss is not liberal
enough for the new york times they got a
real problem on their hands exactly
right and all newsrooms do
because i interviewed one journalism
professor at the cronkite school in
arizona and she was telling me that many
of her students really do ardently
believe that the reason you go into
journalism is to bring your point of
view to the people
as opposed to bring facts and the truth
to the people let the people tell you
what their point of view is and dave
that's the fundamental point newspapers
have analyses newspapers have commentary
if it's on the editorial page if it's on
the nightly part of the fox news hour
with sean hannity or with tucker or with
don lemon at cnn that's opinion and we
get it but when the news itself is
twisted
to represent a point of view we have a
real problem and that's been the case
for decades at the new york times and
infection is a good word it's infected
the mainstream media all over the place
that's why i keep blowing a whistle
throughout this book
you know one of the favorite things i do
in here
is i put pictures up of how the new york
times covered the exact same thing yeah
so when um ruth bader ginsburg passed
away
front page headline this was the
washington post but the front page
headline was pioneer for equality dies
when antonin scalia passed away the same
headline washington post banner headline
was uh something along the lines of
taunted the uh
champion of liberal taunting
something along those lines one was a
pioneer for rights the other taunt to
the left how is this
how is this neutral how is it objective
but it's a point of view
and it's in the papers every day does
that also explain why we sort of
seemingly have like a mass mental health
problem right now that so many people
have bought into this framework that is
dishonest and it doesn't connect with
what they see in real life but it's
constantly pushed on them so everyone
starts feeling crazy about politics one
of the other points i really make in
here that i think is different is we all
know what it's like to be a conservative
and have them look down on us and think
that treat us with disdain for our
habits our views or traditions
but the group that i also argue is
really hurt are liberals
because if everything you see if
everything you're told and if all the
people you're surrounded with say to you
hillary's going to win it's going to be
a landslide what she's going to want
trump has zero chance
and then trump wins
you either have to say how can you
misinform me which they don't do or how
did trump do it it had to be another
reason had to be collusion so you then
are susceptible to people giving you the
misinformation that trump colluded
and then when you hear mueller's
investigating and you watch msnbc you're
told every night the walls are closing
in another shoe dropped and
more questions have
than answers and you've reached the
conclusion trump's on his way out you do
it now with the january 6 committee
trump's going to get indicted isn't he
these people keep fooling themselves
into going down a criminal cul-de-sac
that says the people i don't like in
politics are criminals and somebody's
about to get rid of them and when it
doesn't happen you can't understand it
because everybody thinks the same way
you do
and i do think that contributes to this
feeling that people have a bitterness of
animosity of mental breakdowns in some
cases because what they were told to
expect doesn't match reality
and that's the problem with the liberal
media it's hurting the liberal base of
our country too so i think most people
watching this get sort of the young
journalist quote-unquote journalist i
always have to put air quotes with
journalists but the young kid part of it
that they come in and infect these
things but what do you think at the
corporate level because when we show
clips of msnbc on my show which we do a
couple times a week i call it the
televised mental institution of msnbc
because you would not be able to tell
that it was not broadcasting from a
mental institution when you listen to
some of the crazy things that joy reid
is saying i mean it genuinely
it seems psychotic to me that would be
my my uh prescription on that but what
do you think is happening at the
corporate level like i get at the
newsroom level okay maybe they've been
all infected but this is
msnbc microsoft nbc these are massive
corporate powers
that they're watching this going they
know this can't be true that this
nonsense is not true that they're
spewing as long as it appeals to a
significant enough niche they can make
enough money on advertising revenue and
subscribers
that's all they need
and so they've given up the notion of
serving the country serving all the
people they just need to serve their
niche and if their niche wants to hear
that trump colluded if their niche wants
to hear that the election was uh stacey
abrams actual election was stolen that's
what they'll tell their niche
so again this is technology you know
when you in the older days when you
didn't really have all these niches that
were so easily available to be found on
the internet you have to
tell the news in a broader more fair
sense
they don't have to do that anymore so
that's again reason for pessimism but
here's how these things ultimately do
fix
you know one of the reasons that
hispanic vote is increasingly voting
republican
is because of all this woke stuff all
this you know men can have babies if you
have any bit of traditional in you
you just say who are these people i
can't be part of this thinking and
hispanics are increasingly turning
republican i think one of the solutions
here is the democrats start to lose
their base of support and increasingly
just remain and msnbc just remains
the tellers of tales for upper income
liberal white people
and they've lost working-class
blue-collar people they've start to lose
hispanic voters and if they start to
lose african-americans more than they
already are
that's when they're gonna start to
realize this upper middle income white
niche the upper west side isn't big
enough we need to change that's when
it'll happen so since i have no doubt
you know basically everyone in dc
although maybe some of them won't talk
to you publicly um like do you talk to
any democrats old school democrats say
guys that were across the aisle from you
20 years ago when you were in the
administration that are going we just
lost control of this thing like that
that the train is just completely out of
control we don't know how to stop what's
going on with the democrats right now
yeah i think there's a growing sense of
that and it takes elections it really
takes when a group that you always had
in your corner like the hispanic vote
does start to break 50 50. these are the
things that shock politicians into
changing their behavior and i think joe
manchin is on the front edge of that for
the democratic party kirsten cinema
interestingly as well senator from
arizona
um
it's the bernie sanders the elizabeth
warrens that are killing the party and
you'll notice
it's the appeal to the upper income
white liberal
and that's just the wrong group to
create any type of national
uh consensus from and one of the great
things about american politics is we
have to create broad coalitions to
govern we're not like europe we don't
have six major parties in our
parliaments each of which splits and
then you have to play coalition politics
we have two big parties and if two big
parties can create internal coalitions
they can govern america the democrats
are on their way to proving they're
proving it under biden that they can't
govern america so i want to get a little
more into that but but going a bit more
on the media side you've mentioned this
balkanization a couple of times and that
there's a danger there do you think in
some ways that there's also a um a
silver lining to it which is that the
more that we get balkanized whether it's
geographically as you know i move from
cali to florida
or through the information that we get
that people are
really thinking about
what they believe that they are actually
putting it some of this stuff into
practice whether it's by moving or
finding sources that make sense to them
and ignoring some of the old stuff and
that we just are in a transition phase
it just it just is and there are more
choices now
yeah and the fact is the pendulum always
swings in the united states
and and it goes in one direction for a
while and goes back in another direction
and it never swings that far
and that's one of the great strengths of
our country so i think there's something
to that and i also look at the history
of journalism we're back to the way we
were in 1776 or 1789
when pamphlets really represented news
and my side put out a pamphlet the other
side put out a pamphlet it was all
advocacy
this notion of objective reporting is a
relatively newfound notion that began in
the early to middle on part of the 20th
century
prior to that you really had yellow
journalism on the hearsts and scare
everybody as much as you can and sell
sell the paper for a penny every
afternoon
so
things do swing and change but
eventually people get fed up
and things go back to what is sensible
and that's why i'm hoping it'll return
to what's sensible that's why i wrote
the book it's why i have my
recommendations in there for how to
change newsrooms in journalism schools
and if it doesn't happen in the next
five years or ten years i think it's
still going to happen
because eventually that pendulum always
heads back to the sensible direction
so a lot of people always ask me was it
always this bad and i try to you know
think back i'm 46. i remember the
nightly news on you know abc cbs nbc and
it was basically whether you liked broca
or peter jennings or uh what's his name
dan rather
but that the the structure of the show
and what they covered was basically the
same uh they weren't you know it was
maybe the order was a little bit
different but they pretty much were
covering the same things or walter
cronkite before that do you think there
was too much um
protection over topics that maybe they
weren't talking about back then well
protection over topics what i would say
is there was
too much of a one-sided nature of
storytelling
how often would you see on the news
about a good guy with a gun stopping a
guy with a gun and a killing yeah
because you need a gun control so if a
citizen who had a concealed carry
stopped a crime
they didn't tell you about that because
that would have been the case for
concealed carry the trial of hermit
gosnell which i talk about in my book
probably the greatest serial killer in
american history an abortion doctor who
delivered who thousands upon thousands
of babies he sniffed the spinal cords a
baby's about to be born late term
abortionist
and his trial was suppressed there was
hardly any news coverage of it america's
greatest serial killer why because if
the networks went wall-to-wall with the
coverage of that trial yeah it actually
had people think twice about being
pro-life or pro-choice and in a newsroom
that's yucky to have people who think
pro-life be legitimized nobody thinks
like that inside a newsroom
so there was a absence of coverage and
again this is what great gave way to fox
news box said you're only telling one
side of a story you're leaving on the
cutting room floor so much of american
life
um
so that's what was wrong with the three
networks back in their heyday you know
when reagan was president some 50 or 60
million americans watched abc nbc cbs at
6 30 eastern evening
and now only 20 million do
30 to 35 million went elsewhere they
went to fox and they went to the
diversification of other outlets so when
you were press secretary and there was a
little more honesty there um now when
you watch and it's so out of control and
you mentioned peter ducey we show a lot
of clips of him on the show uh but it's
not just that the pr that the press
themselves are worse it seems like the
press secretaries have gotten much worse
let's say the last two specifically
that sake i mean the woman simply
i don't think could say a true statement
my line on her was always if you asked
her what her favorite color was she
would say four i mean she just couldn't
say anything true and now you got uh
this corrine jean-pierre who actually
seems worse i mean completely
unqualified am i am i overstating it
with these two am i not giving enough
credit to how difficult the job is well
let me put it this way and here i am old
school um the job is hard enough
and i i will not
make fun or take on a fellow
a press secretary
i just don't i don't think it's fitting
for me to do that i understand people or
make the criticisms
i won't be one of those people doing it
by name i just will say their problem is
not a communications problem their
problem is a joe biden judgment decision
policy problem old age problem they have
a lot of other things that they have to
deal with
other people can take on their
communication skills
okay so putting aside the the specifics
of the two of them generally as far as
the administration right now it seems
like so many things are wrong and you
just mentioned that the media doesn't
cover certain things finally it looks
like in the last two weeks
there are suddenly discussions about
what's going on with biden cognitively
and is he up to the job and it's even
leaking into cnn now a whole bunch of us
were talking about it before the
election but is that another piece of
this that they just airlock certain
things and then we can all see it we all
know something's not right he can't read
off the prompter anymore the rambling
the incoherent nonsense not where am i
who's in charge all of this stuff but
now it's finally leaking which means
that eventually it will fully get
through the airlock yeah and not only
those stories which appeared in the new
york times and the poll of democrats
saying they don't want biden to run
which the new york times made that lead
story on the front page look at the
timeless coverage of biden's trip to
saudi arabia it was brutal for joe biden
yeah it's as if a flip has switched new
york times where they've made the cop
the judgment that it's time for a
younger different democrat to take biden
down that we don't want biden to run for
re-election you almost get that sense
that they have an editorial change in
terms of the headlines on the front page
now i'll predict to you dave
it's a passing stage
they'll do this until it doesn't work
and then if biden declares for
reelection all of a sudden the new york
times is going to say look at the vigor
he's got as a 82 year old man look at
how strong he is and especially if the
opponent is donald trump they'll flip
right back to their current mode
but it is something to watch right now
because it is interesting they're giving
biden a tough time recently i'd say to
you also
the press was ridiculously easy on biden
throughout the entire campaign
they had their whole body on the scale
because they wanted trump to be defeated
they suppressed stories that would have
hurt biden his failure to read off the
teleprompter you know one of the
examples i have in my book is he did at
a campaign event for the afl-cio
a young woman said to him threw him a
softball and said how do you get more
people to join a union
and his answer this is all on tv on on
on a biden video his answer was uh
uh uh
move it up there
and you get the answer yeah
the q and the a preloaded on a
teleprompter and until they put the
teleprompter and made it run he didn't
know the answer to how do you get more
people to join a union
what would a normal press corps have
done they'd have pounded the guy he's
about to become possibly the oldest
president in the united states history
if he wins he can't even answer a
question like that did he have a
teleprompter how did he get the answer
written there if he didn't get the queue
ahead of time do you have the people
providing you with audit friendly
audiences giving you questions ahead of
time
everything
was all the ingredients for a feeding
frenzy would you if you were if you were
part of the administration would you be
trying i mean i know they've tried to
hide him he doesn't really do long form
interviews he always gets the notes with
who he's allowed to call on and then if
he rambles too long he says that he's in
trouble like none of it makes any sense
or is optically positive or any of that
but if you if you were press secretary
or you were in the administration right
now and you saw what was going on
what would you be what would you be
advising the president to do at this
point
oh they're it's beyond advice
frankly there's little to nothing they
can do anymore because it's about policy
it's about what's happened to the
country it's about inflation the cost of
living cost of gas energy heating your
home air conditioning your home buying
food buying coffee
the southern border crime i mean can you
name more tangible things that are
hurting the country you know it's not
like social security is going to go
bankrupt in seven years or the medicare
trust fund is going to go bankrupt in
eight it's not these big amorphous
things it's the daily things you feel in
life am i going to get mugged walking
home can i afford the things i need to
buy to feed my family this is what's
happening to our country right now and
it's a particularly hidden lower income
and middle-income people
so it's beyond a speech it's beyond
advice it's events
and the public gets it the country gets
it
the only thing i could suggest for joe
biden if he really wants to change is he
should start going after liberal
prosecutors across the country he should
support the recall of la's district
attorney
if he started to send a different note
that he actually is in the 1990s joe
biden who wants to protect people's
lives and get tough on crime that could
have a different impact bottom might be
seen differently if he did that there's
very little else he can do well actually
to that point i mean does this guy biden
strike you as someone very different
than you knew of say 20 years ago i mean
it's almost like he's sort of the
perfect candidate for the left because
he doesn't know what he believes anymore
he reads anything and he's just ushering
in the destruction that i personally i
think that the more radical people want
i don't think he wants to destroy the
country i just don't think he knows what
he's doing at this point look i've known
joe biden for many decades i used to
work for a different senator from pete
domenici of new mexico i got to know joe
biden and then i knew him when i was at
the white house and i always knew that
joe biden was a blowhard
he was just a talker and he didn't have
much depth he didn't have much substance
as robert gates the former secretary of
defense to george bush and barack obama
said about every foreign policy decision
over the last 30 years joe biden has
gotten wrong
and now that's spread to domestic
decisions too
i mean one of the biggest reasons we
have inflation is because biden insists
on that massive blow out government
spending redistribution package when he
first got elected that he was able to
jam through on a party-line vote
and he doesn't think that contributed to
inflation
um biden just says terrible judgment now
he just wants to spend more money and he
really has not shown the spine to stand
up to the woke left he's really become
bernie sanders running mate as opposed
to the nation's leader
yeah i just don't think he has the
cognitive ability to do it i think if he
did then maybe he would be a little
maybe he'd still be a blowhard but maybe
would be pushing back i just don't think
he can but it's interesting because you
said the thing about that it's not
really about messaging it's about policy
but it's like the messaging has just
been absolutely terrible i mean on any
given day you can get him saying hey
this is putin's price hike and then the
same day you can get his energy
secretary or transportation secretary
saying no this is because we're going
through an energy transition and this is
a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity so it's
not just i mean it's not just the
policies the messaging has made no we're
not going to have inflation inflation's
transitory i hope there's no inflation
like it's all of it kind of i'm not
going to meet with the saudi crown
prince i've met with the smarty crown
princess filling this about a fist bump
as opposed to a handshake no i imagine
leaders around the world are laughing at
joe biden saying he is so weak he has to
pretend he can't even shake a man's hand
if you're going to go go
if you're not going to go don't go but
don't be right in the middle have it
both ways and that's biden's just weak i
think that's a bigger part of it he's
weak and he caved to the woke and that's
defined his presidency and has created
the bad policies that led to the bad
results so the guy that you worked for
george w bush he was he was known as a
guy that would make a flub every now and
again or or say a phrase slightly
slightly odd but when you see biden
doing it now you must be like man i wish
my guy would have got the
long leash
that they're getting yeah george bush
used to joke that he had some issues
with the english language
i think they've called it the american
language
but it was always convivial and
he had inarticulate moments but i don't
think anybody questions his leadership
strength or his decision-making or the
toughness of his policies or his
integrity
and that was a difference
are you still in touch with i assume
you're still in touch uh with president
bush are you surprised that he went so
apolitical i mean i know most presidents
do but he really is just he enjoys
painting it seems like and living on the
ranch and and just doesn't have much to
do with public policy you know one of
the things about him he always
understood that he was going to go in
and get out himself now i remember
during the recount in 2000 when al gore
was working the phones and trying to
influence votes in florida during the
recount george bush was at his ranch
cutting wood
and people thought he was disengaged he
wasn't disengaged he always had this
healthy sense of removal he would go
back to the mansion at night with his
briefing book for the next day and watch
espn
you know i do think he just had a
healthy sense of who he was criticism
would roll off his back he was a strong
leader who made big decisions
but he didn't sweat the typical
washington insider nonsense
and i think that kept him a lot better
in touch with the country i'd like to
finish up with something else because
i've wanted to have you on for quite
some time and we were trying to get you
on last year for the 9 11 anniversary
and you you usually on 9 11 you do a
full twitter recap of what that day was
like and being with the president and
everything else i lived in new york city
at the time much of my family lived in
new york city at the time um and i
remember you i remember obviously george
bush and i remember rudy giuliani and
all of those things all those people um
can you just talk a little bit about
that and and maybe i can get you back on
uh in a couple weeks in in september to
to do a bigger a bigger dive on that but
i just think it's important yeah you
know dave when i when i look back the
thing that strikes me having been at the
president's side for much of that day
and being on board air force one
was how
unemotional it was
for those of us with the president
which is i think in many ways remarkable
because it was probably the most
emotional day anybody alive today has
had um
and it had to be that way you know
everybody the president was kind of just
steely like this the secret service
around him steely like that the military
like that
it was such a seriousness a steadiness
and
i was at the president's side when he
said to the vice president we're at war
and then he picked up what he called the
secretary of defense and said to the
secretary of defense
where at war
and it just sent a chill down my spine
and you know looking back some people
might say well of course we'll be at war
we were attacked
well the next day in the cabinet room
when the president held a meeting with
congressional leaders all of whom were
tremendously supportive
one leader said to the president the
democrat i urge you to use caution in
your rhetoric war is such a scary word
and i just remember thinking to myself
if this isn't war what is
the decision of the president to tell
people that they were at war
sent the direction to everyone to start
planning for what we were going to do
and that was the right and necessary
step to take and it reoriented
reoriented everything we've done since
then it put us on a much stronger ground
against terrorism it's one of the
reasons we haven't been hit again in a
major attack it influenced our thinking
about drone strikes abroad which have
been carried out now not only by george
bush but by barack obama donald trump
and joe biden it created a bipartisan
template for how to protect this country
all of which came from the strength i
think that he exhibited that day but
um
it was it was a time of the
just the utmost seriousness
the utmost weight on our shoulders we
were told by the cia it's not a question
of if it's a question of when the second
wave will be
and that permeated all our thinking
let's finish up flash forwarding now 21
years into 2022 and uh and as a
conservative and as a media
why i guess a media watchdog or
is that a fair phrase or you're a media
watchdog at this point i guess
um
what do you want to happen with the
republicans right now i mean obviously
everyone's talking about this trump
desantis situation
as a new floridian i obviously love my
governor and it's partly why he's partly
why i moved here
i think there's reasons to back trump i
think the machine and he's willing to do
all the all the stuff to fight it what
do you think should happen here i mean
do you want a robust primary do you want
one of them to just get out of the way
is it somebody else what's your thought
well one i hope the president does not
declare prior to the november election
you know this election right now random
on joe biden and the democrats are
losing it badly if it
becomes a choice between joe biden and
donald trump in an indirect fashion it's
only going to help the democrats
look into the future i think there are
three issues for president trump
one is he'll be 78 in 2024
is he healthy enough to be a president
at the age of 78 to 82.
two is what do the polls show about his
potential democratic opponents and how
much are they beating joe biden or
kamala harris or buddha edged by if
they're beating those guys by more than
trump
it's an important sign that donald trump
for all his strengths and weaknesses may
not be our strongest candidate
and then three or maybe he is our
strongest candidate that's why those
polls will be important and primary
voters will pay attention to it
three how many people are running
against president trump
if it's one or two
president trump is being for a fair
fight
if it's three four five president trump
will win with the largest plurality
so as a
analyst those are the three things that
i'm looking at the president's health
the polls against the democrats and the
number of ours who run against donald
trump that will determine whether donald
trump wins or loses potentially a
primary
for presidency by the way to wrap this
up in a nice little bow have you seen
the way the media has been treating
desantis lately where these big
headlines are basically saying he's
trump but he's even worse because he's
competent that's the new move that they
were going to treat anyone like this
right he's got all the bad stuff of
trump plus he's competent that's double
history he takes me right back to my
book and i wrote depression deception
snobbery and bias because i knew the
press did it to donald trump and i blew
the whistle on it
but as we talked earlier they're going
to do it to the next republican too
because they're activists for a cause
and they're not neutral they're not
objective they're not serving their
country when they do that and they will
do it to desantis they'll do it to
whoever our nominee is and it doesn't
matter if the democrat is biden harris
you name who
they're going to do it again ari i've
enjoyed talking to you the book is great
we're going to link to it right down
below and can you stick around for one
more thing we're gonna throw on our
locals community yes i can if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about the media instead of
non-stop yelling check out our media
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out the full episode playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell